[Musik]
willkommen zurück hierbei bild live und
wir wollen direkt mal live in die
bundespressekonferenz hier in berlin
schauen denn gleich wird
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach fragen zu aktuellen corona
lager beantworten mit dabei wird auch
der mediziner leif erik sander sein wir
haben es eben gesehen noch wird gewartet
auf die beiden karl lauterbach wird
sicher sicher auch zum abflachen der
korona sommer welle äußern aber eben
auch sehr spannend pläne für den herbst
da ist ja schon sehr viel durchgedrungen
ist kritik gewisse äusserungen steckt
noch drin es wird ja das eine oder
andere klarstellen nicht dass die
menschen losrennen sich alle drei monate
impfen lassen zum beispiel jahren gerade
seine pläne sind ja sehr in der kritik
also interessant zu sehen sein was karl
lauterbach dann da tatsächlich verkünden
wird wie seine herbst pläne aussehen
werden da schauen wir gleich seine
freien sobald sich da was tut in der
bundespressekonferenz gesehenes bild
live eingeklinkt gehen wir da sofort
live drauf aber jetzt müssen wir erstmal
über gascad sprechende der auf die
barrikaden geht gerd schröder verklagt
nämlich den bundestag jetzt aber jetzt
kommt schon ihr bewegung rein es geht
manchmal ganz schnell das bedeutet
vielleicht ist ja auch ganz konkrete was
zu sagen hat noch moment müssen wir
nicht sofort live ein dass werden
erstmal ein paar fotos gemacht alle
setzen sich hin ein paar minuten haben
wir noch kann ich ihn also einmal
erzählen worum es hier gleich in dieser
sendung gesehen er trägt maske ja
lauterbach kann gar keine massen pflicht
mehr in der bundespressekonferenz aber
der bundesgesundheitsminister hat sie
eben wieder aufgesetzt gehabt jetzt hat
er sie gerade ausgezogen wir sehen hier
noch die presse kollegen die dann noch
ein paar schicke fotos mache ich
natürlich auch daran dass er bis vor
kurzem selbst an corona erkrankt war er
hat jetzt die ganze zeit aus dem
homeoffice gearbeitet obwohl vielfach
glaube ich geimpft war und er sagte er
hätte nicht erwartet auch
die starke die krankheit dann doch
trifft ja muss ich doch relativ heftig
erwischt eine oder andere von ihnen wird
canon tatsächlich nun sind wir aber
natürlich gespannt wie er sich jetzt
eben zum herbst äußern wird welche
maßnahmen kommen denn da jetzt wieder
auf uns zu müssen wir uns da wieder auf
den masten pflicht einstellen während
wir uns auch verbote einstellen das
werden wir eben alles sehr gleich
erfahren wir sehen ist der leiter der
bundespressekonferenz stellt noch kurz
vor vornherein karl lauterbach wird
sprechen gleich
er ist klinikdirektor für infektiologie
an der berliner charité auch wenn sie
ein herzliches willkommen
in zeiten von krone wird diese
pressekonferenz
glaub ich geh stream dann auch live
übertragen deshalb unsere übliche
vorbemerkung die bundespressekonferenz
ist keine institution der
bundesregierung sondern ein unabhängiger
verein von journalistinnen und
journalisten
wir veranstalten pressekonferenzen damit
unsere mitgliedschaft besser informieren
kann sodass der vorrede und jetzt haben
sie das wort hallo doch bitteschön ja
vielen dank vielen dank für die für die
möglichkeit hier unsere positionen
vortragen zu dürfen an ort möchte
zunächst herrn professor wieder und das
robert-koch-institut entschuldigen
urlaubsbedingt kam er heute nicht
teilnehmen heute werde ich unterstützt
durch ein live ihre kinder so sander von
der charité berlin über den stand der
impfungen und über die lage für krone
derzeit berichten
die
situation ist wie folgt zu beschreiben
wir haben eine günstige entwicklung
bei der sommer welle sollen wir wähler
war ja antizipiert worden die sommer
bälle fängt jetzt langsamer an
zurückzugehen sind stetig sinkende
fallzahlen auf die sterblichkeit geht
gott sei dank nach langer zeit jetzt
etwas zurück ist aber immer noch nicht
da wo wir sie gerne hätten
man muss bedenken dass der anteil
der nicht
registrierten fälle gewachsen ist die
dunkelziffer steigt das wissen wir aus
den daten
projektdaten spende des
robert-koch-instituts neuer daten von
professor der brockmann haben uns da in
den letzten tagen erreicht nicht desto
trotz ist der rückgang der fall sei
jetzt kein artefakt sondern ist das
sagen auch diese fehlens praxen des
ärgers wir haben also mit den daten die
wir haben einen robusten rückgang der
fallzahlen auch in anderen europäischen
ländern gesehen haben und das gibt er
sommer grund zur freude
dass es trotzdem kein grund für eine
entwarnung denn die modellierung die es
gibt und auch also die dynamik kba fünf
fälle lassen erwarten dass im herbst
werden wieder mehr aufenthalt in
innenräumen stattfindet noch die schule
wieder begonnen hat dass wir dann wieder
stark steigender fallzahlen erwarten
müssen dass es auch andere gründe jetzt
hatte ich ihnen gleich das
infektionsschutzgesetz noch einmal etwas
näher erläutern werde das was bisher
machen konnten ich bringe aber zunächst
einmal eine sehr also positive nachricht
war sehr gute nachricht von der
entwicklung der impfungen ist davon
auszugehen dass das die person
europäische zulassungsbehörde sich also
mit dem baa1 bivalenten impfstoff am
ersten september schon beschäftigen wird
so dass möglicherweise dann also am 2
september die auslieferung was also
erfolgen könnte und wir haben nachricht
dass es wahrscheinlich dass am 27
september die entsprechende
gremiensitzung zu b a 5 die wahlen
stattfinden würde so dass dann die
auslieferung am 28 september stattfinden
konnte die bundesregierung hat also bei
der eben stoffe in auskömmlicher menge
besorgt und wir werden daher relativ
früh auch beliefert werden das bedeutet
dass die von uns geplante und in
vorbereitung befindliche kampagne dann
auch zeit also nahe stattfinden kann und
wir dort also im prinzip gut unterwegs
sind das gilt auch für viele andere
vorbereitungs städte pandemie rada
beispielsweise
david vorbereitung darauf würde ich aber
nur in frage in frage teilen eingehen
weil ich jetzt also mich konzentrieren
möchte auf den zweiten tag meiner
ausführung nämlich auf das
infektionsschutzgesetz zunächst einmal
ist da der stand also 24 achten wollen
wir mit dem gesetz im kabinett sein so
wie es jetzt aus dem entwurf vorliegt
die begründung wird gerade überarbeitet
hat gestern intensiv gearbeitet anfang
september wurde dann das gesetz im
bundesdeutschen bundestag beschlossen
und in der nächsten woche werden wir
eine schalte mit den leitern der
staatskanzleien haben erneut um also uns
auch mit den ländern auszutauschen
abzustimmen sie wissen dass in der
letzten dass in dieser woche auch eine
gesundheitsminister konferenz
stattgefunden hat am dienstag und wie
gesagt nächster woche hat der
staatskanzleien so dass das verfahren
bisher zeitlich nicht gefährdet ist und
ich komme jetzt zum inhalt des norman
texte selbst das sind ja zwei stufen
beschrieben die erste stufe wird als
winterreifen stufe beschrieben die also
zweite stufe als schneeketten also stufe
man kann er von der ersten und der
zweiten stufe sprechen
begrenze mich daher auf diese wortwahl
im moment die erste stufe funktioniert
wie folgt zunächst einmal ab dem ersten
zehnten würde wenn man jetzt aber von
maßnahmen im öffentlichen verkehr
absieht und in den kliniken
pflegeeinrichtungen über die wir als
bund also bestimmen können ob wir
bestimmte verschärfungen der geltenden
regeln beschlossen haben aber würde dann
länder seit ich die möglichkeit bestehen
ab dem ersten zehnten und zwar incidents
unabhängig dass die länder für den
innenraum einer maske nicht einführen
also nur dass es jeder versteht es ist
eine möglichkeit die ab dem ersten
szenen besteht spielt die residenz eine
rolle spielt keine rolle die länder
können das machen ganz unabhängig von
der incidents müssen sie es dann machen
sie müssen es nicht machen wenn sie es
aber machen dann müssen sie eine
ausnahme vorsehen für die innenräume wo
das masken tragen ersetzt werden kann
durch entweder einen impfausweis
genießen aus welcher testo
dann kann die masken sich aufgehoben
werden und das ist die regelung die wir
eingeführt haben um es den ländern zu
ermöglichen wenn die fans sagen jetzt
nicht ganz so hoch sind dass trotzdem
schon die masken tritt im innenraum
kommt man aber an der masken pflicht
also einfach die ein paar
ausnahmeregelungen vor sie zum beispiel
in der gastronomie es kann man sich
fragen macht so etwas denn dann sind ist
es denn da nicht sinnvoll sofort die
masken pflicht für alle einzuführen ohne
jede ausnahme ohne und das ist
medizinisch also ist das eben kann es
sinnvoll solche ausnahmen zu machen
wieso kann das sinnvoll sein naja wenn
jemand in eine gastwirtschaft in einem
gzb geht mit der maske rhein ist nicht
geimpftes nicht getestet nimmt dann die
maske ab sitzt dann dort eine stunde
ohne also maske weil er speist dann kann
das weniger sicher sein aus wenn er
vorher einen frischen im haus war es
gezeigt hat geht dann zwar ohne maske
zum tisch sitzt dann auch ohne maske war
immer schon gehen somit kann es obwohl
das nicht für den laien sofort plausibel
ist kann es im restaurant sogar eine
zusätzliche sicherheit sein wenn mehr
geimpfte dort sitzen und frisch genesene
dass leute die wieder genesen noch die
eben sind aber die maske angehabt haben
wenn sie zum tisch gehen und das ist
sehr schwierig man muss dann immer sagen
mal erklären dass deshalb sind wir ja
hier zusammen dafür bedanke ich mich
auch aber das ist eine möglichkeit hier
mehr sicherheit anzubieten das ist also
der hintergrund das setzen des ganzen
und also es gibt es zwei argumente die
da immer wieder betont werden müssen war
das argumente sind die werden zum teil
auch vorgebracht gegen diese regelung
auch von denjenigen die die regelung
nicht möchte das erste argument ist dass
das bedeutet doch man muss sich dann
drei alle drei monate impfen lassen
heißt natürlich nicht so für die drei
monate gehen wir davon aus dass dann der
schutz vor infektionen gilt aber die
impfungen wirken natürlich viel länger
und die impf wirkung und auch die sagen
wir der mvhs war es dass von den drei
monaten ja gar nicht berührt somit wäre
es nicht so dass dann alle drei monate
gegeben wurde dass wir erstens kann arzt
wollen wahrscheinlich auch kein arzt tun
so nicht vorgesehen sondern das ist die
dauer wo wir glauben dass die neuen
impfungen auch vor ansteckung schützen
also nicht nur verschwörung verlauf
sondern auch vor ansteckung wenn sich
die studie jetzt so entwickeln dass das
länger zu sagen die neuen impfungen
länger als drei monate vor ansteckung
schützen daran würden wir diesen
zeitraum drei monate verlängert dann
wurde das beispielsweise 4 motor fünf
monate die das kann dann verlängert
werden das steht im gesetz auch drinnen
in der normentwurf somit die drei monate
sind erst mal unsere schätzung auf der
grundlage der daten die wir haben was
man für drei monate auch bei eine
stärkung geschützt ist vor schweren
verlaufs man viel länger geschützt aber
dass man vortrag für drei monate hat
dann quasi im ersatz einer maske weil
man wahrscheinlich vor ansteckung
geschützt ist die masken die strafe muss
das ist die logik dieses also dieser
vorgehensweise also es hat nichts damit
zu tun die impfung gilt nur für drei
monate das hat nichts damit zu tun dass
man sich alle paar monate impfen lassen
muss ist einfach nur von dem was wir
bisher wissen ist man für drei monate
auch vor ansteckung geschützt sein
zweiter punkt und der wird immer
vorgetragen er ist auch nicht also
unbegründet kühlen kann man aber in den
griff bekommen und zwar ist das denn zu
kompliziert also können dann
beispielsweise die restaurants
erschaffen das die wenn jemand reinkommt
tatsächlich prüfen hat dann ist er
frisch geimpftes der frisch getestet ist
der frisch genesen schaffen sie das die
antwort ist sie haben es auch in der
vergangenheit geschafft wir haben auch
bei 3g bei 2 geht los und so haben wir
diese prüfungen gemacht die prüfungen
sind ja gelernt sie werden nur jetzt
vereinfacht werden die vereinfacht
werden vereinfacht indem einfach
schlicht und ergreifend für alle drei
merkmale die es da geht also eine grüne
farbe dann auf den zertifikaten
erscheinen würde also somit man muss
sich das dann so wie folgt vorstellen
wir sehen sehr blaue zertifikate wenn
das jetzt noch einen dreimonats pass
wäre was bei mir hieß nicht aber wenn
das noch ein 3 monats passwörter oder
eine 3 monats genesenen
bestätigung oder ein frischer test von
also gestern dann werden wir hatten wir
immer eine grüne farbe so dass man beim
reinkommen das handy zeigen kann zeigt
die c b a und schon ist die kontrolle
möglich es wird aus vorgetragen ja wie
wenn man das denn dann drinnen
kontrollieren stichproben war also wenn
die leute reingekommen sind wir geht
dann das war leider kann man wenn man
wirklich stichproben machen will kann
man sagen können sie mir noch gerade
nochmal ihren fest zeigen die grünen ihr
grün ist also ihren grünen nachweis
sollte wäre das auch drinnen relativ
einfach kontrollierbar wie gesagt wir
werden das mit den ländern besprechen
dass es nicht den stein gegossen nächste
woche werden wir mit den leitern der
staatskanzleien darüber lange
diskutieren aber ich hatte das also für
umsetzbar und auch eine möglichkeit im
einstieg also in den herbst also
tatsächlich gut klarzukommen letzter
punkt zu dieser ersten stufe rechne ich
denn damit dass die länder das überhaupt
alle machen werden zum ersten zehn oder
wird das ein flickenteppich werden
machen die länder vielleicht diese regel
und gar nicht ich glaube dass länder das
alle machen werden weil ich hoffen
ausgehe dass wir zum ersten zehnter
wieder höhere fallzahlen haben dann
müssen die länder reagieren von daher
glaube ich dass diese regelung zum car
kommt ganz kurz noch zu dieser zweiten
stufe da geht es um höhere instanzen das
ist so eine mischung kritische
infrastruktur ist bedroht in von
intensivstationen sind also in
überlastung möglicherweise schon wir
haben mehr tote mir mehrere fälle dann
kommen zusätzliche also regeln also
kommen hygiene konzepte die vorgegeben
sind dann fallen die ausnahmen für die
masken pflicht im innenraum weg und dann
müssen masken mit jonas auch draußen
getragen werden in den veranstaltungen
wo man sonst die abstände nicht
einhalten kann das kommt aufzug mit
mindestabständen und es kommt zu
obergrenzen sehr wichtig zu obergrenzen
in den innenräumen weil die innenräume
können so über die obergrenzen sicher
gemacht werden die sag ich ja mal höher
die fallzahl sein werden desto
konservativer werden die obergrenzen
sein und somit also werden dann immer
weniger leute sich in den innenräumen
gleichzeitig aufhalten können um also
der
eigenen fahrzeug zu bewegen zu begegnen
hier sind also zwei punkte die ich noch
mal hervorheben will zum einen deshalb
gibt es ja keine grenzwerte einige
länder haben gesagt kollege roger zum
beispiel wieso keine grenzwerte wieso
nicht so und so viele unter uns weiter
naja das ist einfach für die gerichte
aber auch für die nutzung dieser
möglichkeiten sehr viel besser wenn man
die gesamtstruktur der gefährdung
bedingt die gesamtstruktur der bewertung
zum beispiel bei der vaarts aldi
fahrzeug zum beispiel sehr von davon ab
wie viele fälle werden denn überhaupt
getestet wenn ich jetzt eine riesige
dunkelziffer habe ist die fallzahl
vielleicht nicht so aussagekräftig oder
beispielsweise vater ist es nicht
sinnvoll dann gleichzeitig auch auf die
abwasser kontrolle zu schauen weil die
abwasser kontrolle läuft oft den
steigenden fallzahlen
voraus das kann man dann mit bedenken
oder beispielsweise war der
intensivstation lang wie viele leute
liegen auf der intensivstation
das hängt sehr davon ab was das für
fälle sind wenn es zb schwere fälle sind
die lange dort legen dann war sich die
intensivstation der sich lange nicht
lehren werden das aber noch fälle sind
die von operationen herstammen dann ist
es in der regel so die leute liegend
wenige tage auf der intensivstation das
lässt sich dann sehr schnell wieder und
somit also muss man immer mitdenken und
daher ist es schwester hier mit einer
beschreibung der gefahr zu operieren als
dass man lexikon grafisch versucht von
sieben oder acht parametern einen
sozusagen gesamt score zu bilden das
klappt in der regel nicht das macht auch
kein land wirklich erfolgreich und die
beschreibung der gefahr mit den
parametern die wir haben der pandemie
vater wird ja viel genauer sein als was
wir je hatten das ist aus meiner sicht
eine viel bessere grundlage als der
immer wieder gescheiterte versuch mit
also grenzwerten dort zu arbeiten
trotzdem werden was das mit den ländern
noch einmal anhören die länder haben
diese kritik schwungvoll vorgetragen und
wir werden dann sicherlich also in der
nächsten woche auch beispiele von den
ländern hören wie sie sich dass der
nicht vorstellen wir sind nicht in der
lage gewesen und so etwas genauer
vorzustellen wie solche grenzwerte
aussehen aber wenn die länder uns da in
der nächsten woche also informieren
wollen dann sind wir dafür sehr dankbar
und also das
zweite kritikpunkte also wer seine hand
nicht kritikpunkt sommer sagen wir die
zweite frage spielen denn dann überhaupt
tote schwere fälle eine rolle geht es
nur darum und kritische infrastruktur
spielt es geht aller erster linie immer
um schwere fälle tote zu verhindern
longo wie zu verhindern und das steht
auch also in dem norm texte darin also
unter dem punkt 6 wenn ihnen der normen
text also vorliegt bei der begründung
der zweiten stufe steht ausdrücklich
dass es darum gehen muss auch schwere
fälle und sterbefälle zu verhindern und
also die über die überlastung der
kritischen infrastruktur oder der
kliniken ist ja nur ein mittel dafür
also schwere fälle und tote zu
verhindern dass ja kein selbstzweck
sondern das ist ein mittel dafür und
daher haben wir dies damit dass glas
haben wir das auch noch mal in dem text
aufgenommen und arabisch 6
zur begrüßung der zweiten stufe und es
weiter in der begründung noch mal eine
rolle spielen
herzlich lauterbach herr sander
bitteschön ja guten morgen ich möchte
mal beginnen mit so ein bisschen
eindrücken und stimmungsbild jetzt aus
dem sommer
wenn man wenn man sich die vergangenen
beiden jahre ansieht dann hatten wir im
sommer sehr sehr niedrigen zinsen
teilweise im zweistelligen bereich und
wirklich eine wirkliche entspannung auch
im gesundheitswesen auch im öffentlichen
leben und meiner erinnerung nach
verschwand das thema wird auch auf
sozusagen aus der öffentlichen
diskussion
und und das war eben meistens diesem
sommer ja eben nicht so wir haben wir
kennen eine saisonalität von corona
wären die verstärkt infektion machen im
winter das hat natürlich auch damit zu
tun wo man sich aufhält und so weiter
aber wir haben dieses jahr eine richtig
ausgeprägte sommer welle gab es hat
minister ja auch gerade noch einmal
dargelegt zum glück ist die jetzt am
abklingen das hat vor allen dingen mit
der sogenannten b a 5 variante der der
omicron variante zu tun und diese
variante ist sehr sehr stark übertragbar
sie entweicht nochmal der immunantwort
und leider ist es auch so dass die bh 5
variante ihre eigenschaften der gestalt
noch mal verändert hat dass sie wieder
etwas besser auch die tiefen abschnitte
der lunge infizieren kann und
der der unterschied im wesentlichen zu
den vorherigen omikron varianten ist
tatsächlich dass er wieder etwas mehr
patienten auch auf unseren stationen
gesehen haben wie eine lungenentzündung
haben das ganze hat jetzt nicht zu einer
überlastung des systems geführt aber ich
kann ihnen sagen wir haben zeitweise
wirklich auch nach betten gesucht und
hat eine volle kuwait normalstation auch
auf der intensivstation war wieder etwas
mehr betrieb so etwas kannten wir aus
den letzten sommern gar nicht der
unterschied dieser infektionswelle zu
infektionsfällen die wir aus den letzten
jahren kennen ist ja dass die relative
krankheitslast also die zahl der
schweren erkrankungen und todesfälle
gemessen an der gesamtzahl der infektion
die ist natürlich deutlich geringer als
wir uns zum beispiel der del-tabelle
oder eine alpha bälle hatten und der
grund dafür ist dass wir einen hohen
immunisierung grad in der bevölkerung
haben der nimmt auch weiter zu da nimmt
mit infektionen zudem mit vierten zu und
er führt eben dazu das obwohl sehr viele
infektionen da sind nicht mehr ganz so
viele leute schwer krank werden aber was
auch eine falsche darstellung ist meines
erachtens ist das überhaupt niemand mehr
krank wird das muss ich ihnen einfach
aus dem klinikalltag schildern das
stimmt so auch nicht risikopersonen oder
auch andere ungünstige konstellation
können schon auch dazu führen dass mit
diesem neuen omikron varianten auch mal
wieder leute krank werden in der einfach
gemessen an dieser sehr hohen zahl der
infektionen ist immer noch wenig aber in
absoluten zahlen sind es dann trotzdem
patienten die versorgt werden müssen
noch gravierender ist aber das problem
natürlich auch im bereich des personals
da haben wir erhebliche personalausfälle
jetzt mitten im sommer gehabt und auch
das kennt man aus den krankenhäusern
eigentlich nicht im sommer haben wir in
der regel weniger patienten und einen
niedrigen krankenstand und bisher haben
wir teilweise einen sehr hohen
krankenstand gehabt und wir haben auch
sehr viel betrieb auch in den
notaufnahmen das kann man in diesen
registern
notaufnahme registern und ähnlichem auch
ganz gut nachvollziehen das ist also
eigentlich dieses sommerloch was wir
eigentlich kennen wo dann ein bisschen
verschnaufpause auch ist in den
rettungsstellen das haben wir in dem
sinne dieses jahr nicht gehabt
geschuldet der sommer welle und
natürlich aus muss man sagen im
personellen personal steckt natürlich
auch zweieinhalb jahre pandemie mit
hoher belastung in den knochen da ist
sicherlich die belastungsgrenze jetzt
auch teilweise erreicht gewesen so dass
wir in diesem bereich diesen sommer auch
schon
belastungssituationen hatten was für ein
sommer ungewöhnlich ist und wenn man
jetzt in blickrichtung herbst richtet
ist das schon auch ein warnzeichen bei
mir normalerweise auf einem sehr
niedrigen niveau starten im sommer und
dann höheren krankenstand oder eine
höhere krankheitslast bekommen wie
gesagt
aktuell klingt er die sommer welle
wieder ab das ist auch gut so und mein
eindruck ist dass das sind in der
bevölkerung auch öffentlichkeit man
eigentlich so ein bisschen auch nicht
eine möglichkeit für eine
gleichgültigkeit gegenüber dem thema
hier und da wahrnimmt ich kann das
nachvollziehen war letzten endes viele
leute auch selber vielleicht schon mal
infiziert waren dieses thema erkennen
und
man im grunde jetzt ja im öffentlichen
leben auch kaum beschränkungen hat mit
wenigen ausnahmen wo masken in zb in
zügen getragen werden müssen ist ja
spitze das normale leben wir eigentlich
wieder normal ab und das denke ich ist
gut so
aber man sieht natürlich infektionen im
privaten wie im beruflichen umfeld und
letztendlich müssen wir aber natürlich
im hintergrund jetzt schon den blick
etwas richten auf die wintermonate es
natürlich viele bereiche aber
insbesondere jetzt auch noch mal das
gesundheitswesen und und die kritische
infrastruktur und ja die
krankheitsfolgen von cobit 19
und deswegen hatten wir mit dem
expertenrat der bundesregierung vor ein
paar wochen auch schon an dieser stelle
ein ein konzeptpapier vorgestellt in dem
wir
bestimmte szenarien skizziert haben die
wir relativ grob in drei verschiedene
kategorien eingeteilt hatten das eine
wäre ein günstiges szenario es kommt auf
einmal eine variante die sich durchsetzt
die macht nicht mehr krank oder nur noch
sehr sehr wenig leute krank und
immunisiert im grunde die bevölkerung
und wir müssen kaum maßnahmen ergreifen
war einfach trotzdem keine personen in
den krankenhäusern kommen und es kommt
zu arbeitsausfällen kommt das wird dass
günstiges szenario da gibt es ein
basisszenario was ich so aus dieser pa 5
variante diesem bild was wir jetzt sehen
eigentlich heraus entwickelt und ich
glaube aktuell ist die prognose dass
möglicherweise dieses basisszenario in
welcher ausprägung auch immer so im
herbst eines sein könnte mit dem
auseinandersetzen müssen und dieses
szenario schon vorgesehen auch wieder
skizziert das ist hier auch wieder durch
die saisonalität durch diese ganzen
dinge die im winter passieren durch
zusätzliche atemwegserkrankungen die wir
im winter sowieso immer haben dazu
kommen kann dass wir wieder vermehrt
personal aus verlagen dass wir wieder
mehr kranke auf den stationen haben wir
sehen jetzt hier nicht zwangsweise eine
überlastung des systems vor aber etwas
was dann doch bestimmte maßnahmen
vorsieht die man die man ergreifen kann
und zu diesen maßnahmen gehören unter
anderem das tragen von masken den
innenräumen und eventuell auch bestimmte
hygiene konzepte und natürlich auch das
thema impfung spielte da eine rolle und
das thema datenerhebung und und
bestimmung von krankheits last und
belastungsfaktoren im system und viele
dieser dinge finden sich in dem entwurf
der jetzt vorgelegt wurde
ja eigentlich auch wieder
der die die
[Musik]
dieses basisszenario
das hatten wir letzten endes
skizziert vor dem hintergrund dass die
br fünf fälle gerade kam jetzt kann bh
fünf die evolution von viren können wir
nicht wirklich vorhersagen die wird sich
aber weiter entwickeln das ist nicht das
ende sozusagen der fahnenstange und das
kann in beide richtungen gehen zum einen
kann das virus zusätzliche mutationen
bekommen die es noch mal etwas besser in
die lage versetzen der imf antwort
auszuweichen auch das kennen wir jetzt
schon von bh fünf wichtig zum beispiel
wenn man vorher mit einer anderen
omikron variante infiziert war dann geht
nach drei monaten da dieser schutz
anscheinend auch schon wieder deutlich
zurück das sieht man so den ersten daten
den man sehen kann so dass das virus
natürlich sondern immer mittel und wege
sucht wieder infizieren zu können und es
kann aber da in ramsen revolution eben
auch passieren dass ein virus entsteht
was auch wieder mehr krank macht wie zum
beispiel jetzt der fall ist sbr fünf das
zeigen so dänische daten im etwas
stärker krank macht ohne dass wir jetzt
irgend etwas vergleichbares hätten wie
zum beispiel in der del tabelle
zu den impfungen ist es so dass wir oder
oder nochmal ein rückgriff nochmal auf
die maßnahmen stoppt die maßnahmen die
wir genannt hatten und die kirche die
auch geschildert wurden sind alles
maßnahmen die die wahrscheinlichkeit von
infektionen von schweren erkrankungen
von tod reduzieren ich glaube man muss
ein bisschen sowohl seiner masken oder
über über impfung redet von diesen
binären wegkommen das eine ist ein
kompletter schutz und das anderes
überhaupt keinen schutz ja also auch
über die vierte impfung über die wir
sprechen und das tragen von masken
reduziert ja die wahrscheinlichkeit
einer infektion und reduziert den
zufolge auch die wahrscheinlichkeit
schwer erkrankt oder verstirbt oder
longo bett bekommt aber die bringt das
in der regel nicht auf null solche
maßnahmen gibt es in der medizin ganz
selten und so ist es eben jetzt auch
insbesondere mit einem virus zu tun hat
was ich was ich wieder stärker verändert
von daher finde ich es gut diese
maßnahmen so zu betrachten als was hier
sind die haben alle einen beitrag wenn
man sie kombiniert kriegt man auch in
größeren effekt also wie eine maske
trägt dann hat das eben noch einen
stärkeren effekt zu der letzte vierte
impfung da gibt es eine stiko empfehlung
die teilen alle hier im raum ohne rabl
personen die älter sind über 70
demnächst möglicherweise über 60 die
sollten sich relativ zügig impfen lassen
weil wir eben viel infektionen haben das
sind die personen die man auch noch in
den krankenhäusern sieht leute mit dem
wunsch welchen anderen erkrankungen
sollten das ohnehin machen jüngere
personen können abwarten und seien wir
haben gute nachrichten oder zur
angepassten impfstoffen die werden einen
vorteil bringen sie werden die antwort
noch mal verbreitern noch mal wieder
verstärken und die zur verfügung stehen
denke ich es ist ein sehr gutes
impfangebot möglicherweise auch für
weitere personengruppen die dann auch
einen effekt haben und das sehen wir
auch in studien noch mal eine
impfkampagne und auch in
modellberechnung kann dazu führen dass
auch die instanzen runtergehen kann dazu
führen oder oder wird dazu einen effekt
haben beitragen können und natürlich
eben auch die belastung die wir sehen in
der kritischen infrastrukturen im
gesundheitssystem und deswegen bleiben
eigentlich diese verschiedenen maßnahmen
wichtig möglicherweise in der
kombination je nach dem etwas von der
variante wir es zu tun haben wie stark
die infektion ansteigen dass sie
ansteigen werden ist klar und und
deswegen glaube ich wir kennen die
maßnahmen wir müssen sie jetzt seien
klug einsetzen und das adaptiert an die
jeweilige situation finden herzlichen
dank dann kommen wir zu fragen die es
hat buchsteiner
natürlich ausnahme und lassen sie in
ruhe sagt was können sie sich das
vorstellen
welche nicht ist ein punkt reicht es
nicht sagen
vielen dank also so viel offenheit
wollte ich gar nicht antworten bleiben
bei den vorschlag den wir jetzt haben
und den vorschlag finde ich auch richtig
sonst hätte ich ihnen hier nicht
vorgetragen und verteidigt ich bin
einfach in erwartung dessen was die
länder dort also
bringen werden beispielsweise kam er die
kritik machen wir konkrete also man will
konkrete
schwellenwerte um die zweite stufe zu
fahren das glaube ich wird nicht
funktionieren aber wenn man so etwas
vorschlägt dann muss man auch ein
vorschlag bringen wie man sich das
vorstellen wurde ich hatte es nicht 14
vorn springen und zum zweiten ich glaube
auch nicht dass die länder uns
vorschlagen werden dass wir von tag eins
an erster zehnter das war dann die
allgemeiner masken pflicht ausnahmslos
also einführen werden
somit also glaube ich wird es zum
schluss mit dem vorschlag den ich in die
haut gebracht habe bleiben
[Musik]
also die korona sprechstunde sondern was
mal mit karl lauterbach und charité
professor leif erik santer fasst man mal
ganz kurz zusammen als er sieben tage
incidents das ist die gute nachricht sie
ist weiter gesunken und zwar um 27
prozent in der vergangenen woche aber
karl lauterbach sagt es gibt keinen
grund waren weil es die maßnahmen im
herbst dann geht da gab es auch nicht
viel neues ehrlich gesagt gesagt wir
ganz deutlich wir bleiben bei dem was
ich bereits vorgestellte er habe das
bedeutet wir müssen uns eventuell wieder
auf massen pflicht und geschlossenen
räumen einstellen und die länder dürfen
darüber auf eigene faust entscheiden so
froh dass noch sommer ist da schon eine
ganz kurze pausen und sind gleich wieder
für sie da hierbei bild live ist lang
[Musik]